you have claimed that you are a bit
psychic you think you're a bit psychic
is that true or you have a little bit of
a psychic abilities
so there's like a there's a history in
my family i had a
a great grandmother who was blind but
could see spirits and so i have stuff in
that fam and my family of either
it's legitimate or people think that we
are psychic i think everyone has some
sort of
psychic ability it's just about the
brain being uh open and you're using
your brain more than other people
um but yeah i mean i'm not like people
always ask me to come on and do readings
and stuff like that and i'm not a
professional
right but i think it's fair to say i
think you can say you feel like you have
some
spiritual connection to what's happening
around you and you believe in astrology
you believe that astrology can tell you
about people is that right
yeah i mean i don't live my life by it
but i do think that
it's it's it has its merits just like
neuroscience and uh
astronomy and all sorts of things so i
do check on people usually i do their
charts
if i'm going to be working with them for
long periods of time so if you're going
to work with someone like a director or
something like that you ask them
what's your astrological sign no no it's
so much more complicated and i ask for a
birth time birthplace
um i need the specifics but i also go i
study a lot like the myers-briggs
psychology uh tests and the enneagram
tests the psychological types and so i
tend to
try and learn who people are by asking
really uncomfortable questions like
when i first meet someone i might ask
them where you breastfed as a child
okay that's one of the first things i
ask okay so
where were you breastfed were you was i
breastfed yeah i come from a family that
doesn't talk about any of that [ __ ]
i don't think my parents have met each
other formally uh
um but i i believe i was i'm gonna say i
was not breastfed i'm gonna say that
you ever see your mother naked no
i didn't i didn't see my magazine no i'm
kidding
uh come on
it was a national geographic
god's sake you're animals uh no i don't
think i was breastfed
and i and i never seen my mom naked so
that informs me because
a child's first experience of the mother
especially a boy's first experience of
the mother that's your first love and
that color is how you
see women for the rest of your life so
it's helpful for me to know
what is that what does that tell you
about how i see women then if i wasn't
breastfed
and i've never seen my mom naked what
does that say
you may perceive that there is a lack of
like warmth and nurturing coming from
women and you may be
afraid of women on some level bingo
you're good
i feel like you were definitely
breastfed oh yeah
oh yeah now you when you mean you mean
just as a child
you're really good at this yeah yeah